Alice:这是露西亚做的小狗
Alice: This little dog was made by Lucia.
Alice:这是我做的小狗
Alice: This little dog was made by me.
Alice:嗯好的阿姨
Alice: Uh, okay, Auntie.
阿姨：这袋子不要了吧
Auntie: We don't need this bag, right?
Alice:嗯不要了
Alice: Yeah, we don't need it.
阿姨：有不要的吗
Auntie: Is there anything you don't need?
Alice:嗯都不要
Alice: Yeah, we don't need any of it.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
阿姨：这里面的菜纸盆不要了吧
Auntie: We don't need the vegetable paper plate inside, right?
Alice:都不要了
Alice: We don't need any of it.
Alice:还有这个阿姨
Alice: And this one too, Auntie.
Alice:啊这个
Alice: Ah, this one.
Alice:我一会装垃圾用
Alice: I'll use this to hold trash later.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Alice:啊这个要的
Alice: Ah, we need this one.